ah the great outdoors in just a
three-hour drive you can explore the
hidden and not so hidden gems of Kanab
Utah thanks to the Kane County Office of
Tourism the sponsors of this segment
here's an ideal Kanab itinerary
Jeanette welcome to Las Vegas now
hi Rocky so glad to be here today we are
so happy to have you I know you're
telling Vegas how to visit Kanab so what
is Kanab known for well we are a small
town of a population of 5 000 people
we're located three miles from the
Arizona border and we're surrounded by
national parks we've got Zion Bryce
Canyon and the north rim of the Grand
Canyon surrounding us but along with
that we've got a lot of our own cool
unique hidden gems okay what are those
hidden gems because you mentioned those
Parks I see photos I cannot wait to
visit but what are the hidden gems yes
definitely visit the parks But be sure
and stay long enough to stay a while and
Canal uh we're home to the longest Slot
Canyon in the United States it's 16
miles long it's called butt skin Gulch
it's a short drive east of Kanab and
then you can enter the Slot Canyon and
go as long as you want turn around and
come out we've also got Best Friends
Animal Sanctuary the largest no-kill
animal sanctuary in the United States
where at any given time there'll be up
to 1600 cats dogs pigs bunnies horses
and you can volunteer your time there
and not only that Knapp has a unique
little Hollywood history back in the 40s
and 50s over 250 westerns were filmed in
and around the Kanab area and there's
still a lot of memorabilia in town and
at some of our local hotels and
restaurants
oh that is so cool is there is there a
map or some kind of you know guide that
we can grab when we get to Kanab
definitely you can come into our office
of Tourism where we have over 50 trail
maps to all different types of uh unique
hidden gems around the area so you would
never be bored and there's pla there's
hikes north south east west all over
cool unique features that aren't very
crowded either that's great a little
change up from Vegas A Perfect Getaway
not too far away
um how many days would you recommend
someone or their family stay well a
weekend you could do it in a weekend it
just depends if you want to see our
stuff and the parks you know you
actually would probably want a day for
each Park but then we get that all the
time people saying I need to stay a
little longer because there's so much
here so maybe a weekend and add a day a
long weekend would probably be great
okay that sounds lovely now you are born
and raised in Kanab that's right
um any advice you would give you know to
people planning their Canal trip well my
advice would be just to be sure and
check out those Maps stop in and talk to
some of our locals people are really
friendly here and they want to share
we've got some great guide companies
that are locals like me who are wanting
to share the things we grew up doing and
now they've made them into Fun exciting
tours thank you Jeanette can't wait to
see you here
thank you Kane County Office of Tourism
for sponsoring that segment for more
just visit southernutah.com a lot to
explore we will be right back on